hustle ends not with a triumphant game
montage or a buzzer beating score but
with a quieter sweeter ending how does
the film set all this up this is the
ending of hustle explained
it's been an unthinkable three years
since adam sandler led stress tests
worldwide to malfunction following his
critically acclaimed performance as
howard ratner in uncut gems now the
comedy icon is back playing things
straight once again this time on the
basketball court in the new hugely
impressive underdog drama hustle while
arguably not getting as much attention
as his last dramatic endeavor the film
has earned a high rotten tomato score
with sandler earning major points for
his performance here too
i mean i couldn't take my eyes off of
you
it got me so excited
you're a fantasy for a guy like me
while some underdog stories are all
about going against the odds hustle
makes a conscious effort both in its
display and story direction to ensure
that the passion for the sport is the
most important thing
as stan initially says to his star
talent during his first pep talk i love
this game i live this game and there's
one thousand other guys waiting in the
wings obsessed with this game
obsession is going to be talent every
time
you got all the talent in the world but
are you obsessed
cliched as it may be it's an element
that leads to every successful step stan
beau make in hustle it's how stan found
beau in the first place out on a worn
down court and knowing he was the best
person on it it's how they retaliate
against 76ers co-owner vince merrick and
his dirty tactics to besmirch beau's
name before it's even blown up and it's
how beau finally fights back against the
trash talk from rising star kermit wilts
in what might be one of the most
stress-free rematches in sports movie
history
it might be another philadelphia set
story but besides a stone's steps nod to
rocky hustle sees its hoop star having
not won but two rematches in one film
after merrick's potential star gets
inside cruz's head during his nba intro
kermit wilts does it again taking trash
talk to another level by involving his
family it's an encounter that tips beau
over the edge seemingly blowing his
chances and sending him back to spain
that is until stan gets a call from leon
rich who is hosting a private game for
players and managers to attend it's a
turning point in the film and although
it doesn't increase the stakes riding on
it it highlights the beauty of the sport
and the love from those involved in it
when bo and stan step inside the court
it's a surprisingly stress-free scene
there's no countdown on the clock no
gut-wrenching pep talk with the sports
star caked in tears and sweat stan
offers one last piece of advice
i'm gonna say one last inspirational
thing to you
they can't kill you if you're already
dead
and with that beau comes alive the
passion that drew stand to him in the
first place shining bright after cruz
finally wins his face off with wilts
stan is left confident that his
discovery is on the right path to
success before the screen cuts to white
and we shoot to five months later from
that point we find stan back at wells
fargo center home of the 76ers and his
new workplace as acting coach heading
out into the arena he sees his wife
teresa in the stand as well as his
former pupil beau on the other side of
the court after his successful display
it appears that beau was signed for the
boston celtics it's not the traditional
way to close things out but one that
sees these two friends right where they
want to be it's also an ending that
lines perfectly with director jeremiah
zagger's process for putting hustle
together speaking to indy wire the
director who has more documentary
credits than feature films acknowledge
that this would be a familiar story that
aligns with his previous work
this was not subversive it's a sports
story that's been told a lot my ethos is
to tell stories that feel real but like
a dream at the same time keeping that in
mind it makes sense that he connected so
well to this movie and its finale it is
a story that ends authentically with two
talents who love and live for the game
succeeding you really can't knock the
hustle check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]